[Music]
millions of Americans are gonna be
throwing Cinco de Mayo parties okay but
let's face it with the economy in rough
shape most people are on kind of a tight
budget so here with some money saving
do-it-yourself Cinco de Mayo tips is
once again our prop master bill tall
bill pick a box of fruit loops hit it
with a baseball bat
boom pinata
[Music]
it's not a pinata here's Bill with
another tip take an umbrella rip off the
handle boom sombrero here's another one
take your regular beer replace half of
it with water boom Corona
[Applause]
aren't they have sponsors sometimes what
are you doing here's another one
take some avocados smash it with a mini
fridge boom
guacamole
[Applause]
take an empty tin can fill it with old
baby teeth boom Muraki another one ask
your partner to come inside for a minute
tell him he's fired
boom Mexican Independence
[Applause]
take some chloroform breathe it in boom
siesta money saving not sown even cost
anything free these are just getting
stupid I don't even want to see another
one
take a margarita hand it to my wife in
bed boom
frozen margarita
[Applause]